das ist wie eine bombe eingeschlagen die
usa können bei ihren zahlreichen
ufo-sichtungen nicht ausschließen dass
es sich um flugobjekte einer
außerirdischen zivilisation handelt und
auch einer der renommiertesten
astrophysiker weltweit professor im loeb
bestätigt diese möglichkeit explizit wow
werden wir also tatsächlich von aliens
beobachtet x1 in future hier gibt es
drei mal pro woche spannendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
diese studie ist wie eine bombe
eingeschlagen seit jahrzehnten wird
abgewickelt die vermutung zu fuß in den
bereich der fantastereien verband und
jetzt das us geheimdienste und das
us-verteidigungsministerium das pentagon
können nicht ausschließen dass es sich
bei 143 sichtungen von unbekannten
flugobjekten kurz nicht um flugobjekte
von einer außerirdischen zivilisation
handelt und 18 dieser beobachtungen die
inzwischen kurz an identifizieren
auf deutsch nicht identifizierte luft
phänomene genannt werden sind
unerklärlich flugobjekte mit diesem
verhalten gibt es auf der erde
nach bisherigem wissen nicht teilweise
wurden die mysteriösen objekte über
militärisch gesperrten luftraum
gesichtet ja sogar überstunden und das
viele tage hintereinander
unter anderem geht es aber video aus dem
jahr 2004 zwei us kampfpiloten hatten
wirklich erstaunliches zu berichten
demnach hatten sie ein mysteriöses
objekt etwa 15 meter oberhalb der
wasseroberfläche über dem pazifik
aufgespürt es sei nicht nur 13 meter
lang gewesen sondern habe sich auch in
einer unvorstellbaren geschwindigkeit
fortbewegt allerdings erst als die
piloten sich immer weiter näherten dazu
einer der piloten in einem interview mit
der times es beschleunigte sich wie
nichts was ich jemals gesehen habe
die piloten seien dann weiter zu ihrem
treffpunkt geflogen etwa hundert
kilometer entfernt dort entdeckten sie
das objekt dann wieder
demnach muss es die strecke in sehr
kurzer zeit zurückgelegt haben genau
diese merkmale werden in allen videos
offenbart die beobachtet
objekte beschleunigen extrem schnell und
verschwinden plötzlich von der einen auf
die andere sekunde die augenzeugen des
us-militärs berichten von einer
überschallgeschwindigkeit in bis zu
10.000 metern höhe und das ohne
sichtbaren antrieb auch abgaswolken
hatten die mysteriösen objekte demnach
nicht hinter sich hergezogen
und genau das lässt nach ansicht der
piloten nur eine schlussfolgerung zu
menschen können nicht dahinter stecken
denn dafür sei die beschleunigung viel
zu unvermittelt passiert und das in
einem raschen wechsel mit abrupten stopp
dazu sagte de pilot ryan grey's in einem
interview mit der new york times
geschwindigkeit bringt dich nicht um
anhalten bring dich um oder
beschleunigungen die schlussfolgerung
die objekte sind in jedem fall ohne
besatzung unterwegs deshalb sind die us
geheimdienste und das pentagon auch
alarmiert denn wenn es flugobjekte von
der erde sind dann wären sie extrem
gefährlich und würden eine bedrohung der
nationalen sicherheit darstellt da wäre
es quasi noch beruhigend wenn es nur
alien sondern wären die uns beobachten
würden so oder so weder die us regierung
geht davon aus dass die flugobjekte eine
besatzung haben noch astrophysiker zu
abrupt sind die flugbewegungen
auch louis elizondo der jahrelang das
geheime untersuchungsprogramm des
us-verteidigungsministeriums geleitet
hatte macht sich sorgen
auch er befürchtet dass die us unsere
sicherheit gefährden könnten zitat
stellen sie sich eine technologie vor
die 600 bis 700 fache g kräfte erreicht
und aushält und 13.000 meilen pro stunde
schafft eine technologie die das radar
meiden kann und sie sowohl durch die
luft als auch im und unter wasser und
vermutlich auch durch den weltraum
fortbewegen kann die zu dem aber keine
offenkundigen anzeichen für irgendeinen
uns bekannten antrieb auf zeigt keine
tragflächen besitzt keine veränderlichen
oberflächen und dennoch den natürlichen
effekten der irdischen schwerkraft
trotzt diese technologie ist allem was
wir bekanntermaßen in unserem eigenen
militärisch technologischen inventar
besitzen absolut und haushoch überlegen
und so hat der us kongress die
geheimdienste und das us pentagon
aufgefordert einen aktuellen bericht zu
schreiben
thema der aktuelle stand des wissens und
zudem eine beurteilung der daraus
resultierende gefahrenlage
der jetzt erschienene bericht dazu sagt
christopher mellon der unter dem us
präsidenten bill clinton und george
cabrio bus stellvertretender
verteidigungsminister
für geheimdienste war was das pentagon
bestätigt ist dass es tatsächlich
flugobjekte gibt die eingeschränkten
luftraum verletzten
das ist passiert und passiert weiter und
wir wissen nicht woher sie kommen wir
verstehen die technologie nicht
jetzt sollen forschende diesen
phänomenen endlich auf den grund gehen
philipp aleris ist einer von ihnen als
ufologen würde er sich nicht bezeichnen
er will einfach herausfinden was das ist
was da am himmel passiert er will ein
automatisiertes alarmsystem aufbauen das
mit kameras und sensoren für strahlung
schwerkraft magnetfeld den himmel
beobachtet 24 stunden rund um die uhr
und rund um den globus soll es nach oben
schauen und wirklich interessante
sichtung kartieren und analysieren ein
anstrengender job schon heute
beschäftigt sich all jenes mit info bzw
absichten am tag arbeitet er bei der
europäischen raumfahrt agentur esa und
betreut dort das kopernikus umwelt
satellitenprogramm in der nacht
analysiert er meldung zu unerklärlichen
himmelserscheinungen ab reporting- so
der name des meldesystems um das er sich
kümmert und die meisten meldungen sind
müll ungenau unlogisch unscharfe und
verwackelte bilder beschilderung und das
allermeiste lässt sich erklären wolken
planeten zb die helle venus satelliten
wie starling vögel und so weiter und so
fort doch immer wieder gibt es seltsame
beobachtungen die eben nicht erklärbar
sind wie jetzt auch beim amerikanischen
bericht vom pentagon und den us
geheimdiensten irgendetwas ist da und er
will wissen was als wissenschafter
erhofft er sich erkenntnisse und da gibt
es halt einige möglichkeiten
es könnten bisher unbekannte natürliche
erscheinung sein die zum beispiel die
entwicklung neuer technologien
ermöglichen oder eben doch waffensysteme
aus china oder russland die dann
tatsächlich eine gefahr darstellen
würden oder eben doch raumschiffe oder
sonden von außerirdischen und da ist es
gar nicht so skeptisch sprich er hält es
tatsächlich für möglich und evernote ist
ja nicht irgendjemand wir hatten ihnen
ja hier bei pixum exklusiv zur mur
interview dem ersten detektierten
interstellaren objekt das durch unser
sonnensystem
dem geflogen ist loeb ist einer der
renommiertesten astrophysiker der welt
und leiter der astronomischen fakultät
an einer der besten universitäten der
welt hat in den usa
er hält weiterhin an der these fest dass
humor der rest einer außerirdischen
sonne oder eine außerirdische sonde
selbst ist sein ansatz ist logisch
seiner auffassung nach kristallisiert
sich immer weiter heraus das leben keine
ausnahme sondern die regel im universum
ist inzwischen hat sich ja auch
herausgestellt dass die wichtigsten
elemente für die entstehung des lebens
wahrscheinlich überall im weltall
vorkommen wenn das so ist so loeb dann
ist es eben nicht unwahrscheinlich dass
wir auf spuren von intelligentem leben
in unserem umfeld stoßen das kann eben
eine sonde wie humor nur sein oder der
rest davon oder eben jetzt auch sondern
eine außerirdische spezies in der
erdatmosphäre flugobjekte mit einer
besatzung schließt lob auch aus weil
sich die ufos oder ob es ebenso schnell
bewegen bzw anhalten und beschleunigen
dass das überhaupt nicht überleben
könnte sprich und jetzt kommt s er geht
davon aus dass es sich um objekte einer
außerirdischen spezies handeln könnte
die sich aber wahrscheinlich autark oder
ferngesteuert in unserer atmosphäre
bewegen
unabhängig davon dass eigentlich nichts
klar ist das ist schon absolut mind
blowing das renommierte fachleute
inzwischen die these für nicht
unwahrscheinlich halten dass es
tatsächlich flugobjekte von
außerirdischen spezies sein könnten das
ist wirklich eine komplette
richtungsänderung der diskussion die
damit aus der schmuddelecke der
verschwörungstheorien raus ist trotzdem
und das ist wissenschaft theoretisch
sehr sehr wichtig niemand wirklich
niemand sagt dass das von außerirdischen
ist wer das jetzt tut der bleibt ein
verschwörungstheoretiker
es gibt keinen einzigen beleg dafür aber
es besteht die möglichkeit und das
alleine schon ist bahnbrechend apple
hier bei uns in einem wirklich extrem
spannenden exklusiv-interview
harvard-professor wir sind nicht allein
exklusiv interview zur mur und aliens
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
hier direkt unter dem video oder unter
jedem anderen klick zum video ist
kostenlos und macht schlau
bis da
bleibt dran